barack obama on this podcast was
discussing
reparations for slavery a radical and
sort of ridiculous proposal by the
vantage of 2021
obama says that the reason we never got
reparations
the politics of white resistance what i
saw during my presidency was that
the politics of
white resistance and resentment
the talk of welfare queens and
the talk of the undeserving poor
and the backlash against affirmative
action
all that made the
prospect of actually proposing
any kind of coherent meaningful
reparations program struck me
as politically
not only a non-starter
but potentially counterproductive
because of those white people with their
resistance
and their resentment we couldn't get
reparations now
first of all i love too that he lumps
affirmative action in there as though
it's somehow unnatural to resent
having a disadvantage when you're
applying to college or
or a job you know yes oh there's
it's the politics of asian resentment
that they don't accept affirmative
action
at harvard and yale that they don't
accept being disadvantaged by the
admissions committee
uh because of all their very white asian
privilege
or asian white privilege i don't know
i'm very confused but he's also just
wrong on the facts here uh black people
do not
uh support affirmative action or do not
support reparations
overwhelmingly either so according to a
reuters ipsos poll from 2020 one in five
americans generally said that we should
use taxpayer money
to pay damages to descendants of
enslaved people in america one in five
people believe this eighty percent of
republicans
oppose reparations two-thirds of
democrats are not supportive of
reparations
ten percent of whites are supportive of
reparations
only half of black people are supportive
of reparations
this is a very radical view and
a proposal that is supported by a very
small number of americans
and it doesn't break down cleanly on
racial lines
if what barack obama is saying is true
then you'd say basically no white people
support reparations which is
essentially true but all the black
people support reparation that's not
true
only half of black people support
reparations and the overwhelming
majority of americans oppose it because
it's an incoherent policy he says
you know in order for us to have a
coherent policy
we would need all this white support
there is no coherent policy
slavery was abolished 150 years ago
you already even at the time of
emancipation you would have had a little
bit of trouble with
reparations but at least you could you
know 40 acres in a mule you could have
done it
but now generation after generation
after generation many people
descended from slaves many people also
many of those same people descended from
white people the
we've mentioned on this show before the
first officially declared slave owner in
the american tradition was a black
angolan guy named anthony johnson that's
kind of weird
do his descendants get reparations do
recent immigrants
from africa get reparations it would be
very difficult how do you prove that
sort of thing
but the real distinction here is not a
racial one it's a radical one
people who share barack obama's radical
politics and people who do not
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]